hello guys I should be live
it's a 10:30 10:30 p.m. Monday night
last night I streamed around midnight
and was tired I'm still tired but not as
tire is yesterday so hopefully I'll get
some interesting games in instructive
games I am in accepting challenges so if
anyone wants to challenge me feel free
but in the meantime let's do at least
one puzzle but let's do a more difficult
puzzle practice wait o puzzles there we
go
that makes sense hello two people in the
chat hello cool guy hello ghost breeze I
am live okay that's a good sign I have a
couple challenges already but let's
solve this first this is white to move
black just played rukka fates
seems like black is almost stuck because
the rook is kind of tied down pawn can't
take is an I take question is how to
make progress for a white g4 comes to
mind
King d7 comes to mind
King g7 could be very strong because II
seven becomes a threat and I don't know
if black can stop that it's a problem
for black if pawn takes pawn Knight take
and there's a fork otherwise King d7
whatever else black does is a seven
coming I guess King G seven rook e8 e 7r
okay seven check King g6 rook a six king
c5 so problem for black the pawn is
constantly threatening to promote the
rook moves back to a8 then there should
be like knight c6 so let's play King d7
unless I want to play king g6 which is
also very similar but that allows rook
e8 so King g7 and easy peasy okay that
was nice I could go back and just see
what would happen was the exact line he
seven and the king should go to c5 if
the rook goes back oh I was saying
knight c6 which doesn't work at all
Knight a got fives a nice move though
with check idea of rook to Yeats okay so
that was a warm-up hello to more people
hello cake rats
anytime control yeah anytime control is
fine just not correspondence chess
how could would how would could I be
your mentee there's a coach command
there should be a coach command I have a
coaching profile on me chess so you can
check that out I'm in Samadhi a Kover
good to see you guys
why not chess tempo because Lee chess is
easier and my my framing is built for
Lee chess Jimmy Ackerman to Tito okay
let's go and accept someone let's uh
let's Asiri I'm Seri with me give me a
random number Mon Siri give me a random
number between one and seven it's fine
no okay why why'd you ask me good luck
I've not played them before I think he's
challenged me several times let's play
do I want to play let's play d5 I'm
playing d5 lately you must move horse
what
you must move horse 2 g 5 g 5 - f 7 this
is like half English and half Spanish
what does knee val mean I don't speak
Spanish I'm sorry I mean I speak a
little Spanish yo hablo poca español
pero no hablo mucho espanol how many
people in the chat speak Spanish I could
try and just play a game and talk
Spanish but I feel like most people
would not understand
let's keep developing c3 signifies that
he might capture on c5 and go for b4 but
okay he's going for a stander in London
I didn't even react like when he played
the London it's just so common now I'm
just I'm just so used to it hey Leandre
tests is also from out Argentina it's
been a lot of people from Argentina
watching at least lately okay so I'm
liking this setup I've had this out
countless times from the white side and
from the black side like the structure
with the half open a file double pawns
double pawns are very strong in this
case cuz they'll allow me to tap on
storm elastic hold has to go to bed okay
goodnight elastic hold maybe see you
tomorrow I don't have like a set stream
schedule for this week but yeah the
streams are a bit sporadic
this week is still crazy I will try and
do like a more morning stream maybe
Wednesday now actually Wednesday is
achat kama Rena Kings so maybe I'll do
like a leech a stream in the morning
then chest calm stream in the afternoon
we'll see anyway let's focus on this
game because this is just the beginning
of how you take down the London
I'm currently threatening this I was
threatening to take on beat one and then
win a two but nine a three is I guess a
useful move also slowing down this B 4 B
6 B 5 B for advance and usually light
wants to play Knight B 5 so there's a
really interesting move here which I
think I can get away with and that's the
type of move looks uncalled for
but I think I'm going to play it I'm
inspired by Magnus not gonna sacrifice
exchange yesterday had a really nice
kind of positional grind and rook take a
three it's actually a move that I've
seen before I think I actually played
this earlier today in a bullet game too
and it just leads to an easy position
for black to play like the B files
opened up but he can't access b1 because
of my bishop and meanwhile I'm just
gonna win the pawn and then have threats
of Bishop b2 and in many cases I'll
bring a rook to eight later and win the
a pawn and then later I'll go for B 5 B
4 so it's a deep sac but I think like
even in a slower game this should be
this should be okay I don't lend your
men played this I know it was this exact
position he played in some very similar
position he beat like a strong player
with it
I think it's one of those things like if
you turn on the computer the computer
won't be so impressed but from a
practical standpoint it's it's difficult
for whites but I guess we'll find out
so Bishop take a3 rook b1 he's just
giving me the exchange back I guess he
wants to win this pawn which I don't
think he can win because I have 97 so I
think I'll just take the rook and play
Knight d7 now I'm up upon we're so
generous to each other this game giving
each other exchanges and pawns I'm
realizing maybe it's not so easy but I
have to start with 97 yeah let's play 97
yeah this is a reason why it's not so
easy because he does win back the pot
the good thing for me is his bishop
might get awkward and also
so I have like a couple Tempe here and
to try and do something but I'm not
entirely sure if I can make use of it
like the first move that comes to mind
is King g7 mm he's gonna take and if we
trade I've work be it in the end
kind of passive looking but simple idea
of bringing the king to c7 looks very
reasonable it was very possible we could
trade down and test some off the Clarke
Bishop ending like 95 we trade nights
and then it'll actually be slightly
better because this is a long-term
weakness on c3 just fixed on the dark
square so any other option apart from
king e7 I've 98 like 98 immediately
defending this pawn so then after he
takes we could trade and then I play I
play this King d7 to c7 yeah I don't
know I'm gonna play keen e7 this is
simple enough and maybe I'll think after
he takes on b6 whether or not I want to
trade because I also have rook e8 rook
e8 Bishop c7 then Bishop d6 could be an
option more arrows says Camel Clutch
sure the only reason ignorant a expects
me is for using leech s so you don't
respect me for any other reason I likely
chess but pretty soon I'll probably do
some some of the arena Kings chess comm
tournaments but for more instructive
streams I I mean Lee chess is still
easier in terms of just in terms of like
drawing arrows even
and going over games and sharing games
and now that seven man table base which
is incredible
props to me chess so he's thinking I
mean if he doesn't take the pawn I just
want to play rook eight and soon when
the a to pawn
she wondering if he plays Bishop to e6 I
could throw in this move immediately
trying to shut down his Bishop Bishop d6
Bishop d6 because at first I was
thinking Bishop c5 and trades could
happen and he wins b7 but I just take
with the Bishop I take with a knight and
he has he plays rook b5 I could play
King d6 so it all starts with this move
camel clutch sure wanted more arrows so
he's getting more arrows I think the
idea is just to play rook 8 to a 6 and I
attack I would in some case chop the
bishop I also attacked the a to pawn so
there's a few things for him to worry
about and these two pieces are useless
for him
yeah that's why you should always
consider multiple options because like
originally I almost pre moved night take
b6 but whenever you play a game I told
my it my younger students because I
think it's important to develop such a
habit but before you make any move you
should consider at least two options you
can slow you down and just get you to at
least be in a situation where you can
have a choice B in the situation to
least acknowledge the best move may I
have an explanation of why accepting BB
pawns was good for two reasons
going back in time as my opponent is
thinking having double pawns and allows
open file this is very common in many
different types of positions where like
material be equal we both have eight
pawns but I have the one half open file
gives me activity the second reason is
it helps contribute to the space
advantage I control more space than the
Queen side and in many cases I play d4
and there's many middle game situations
where I'll play d4 will trade on c3 and
then I will play before again ah so I
can't draw like a yellow arrow over a
green arrow I tried though that was
interesting how did that happen okay
it's my move let's go to the know let's
go to the current position
a4 I figure out about this move he wants
to play a5 but I'm still gonna put my
rook I hate this Bishop should still be
stuck I'm gonna win at least upon he'll
play a 5
and then maybe I'll play and I could
take I could play like rook a6 that move
I didn't see coming
I just want to attack c3
I mean maybe I'll just play rock a6 and
with a pond there's only way to defend
the bishop is to push the pond that I
take actually there's a funny line if a
five-night take a five bishop take a
five rook take a five forked 87
I've rook a eight and end and I'll win
the bishop back rank problems now I'm
falling behind in the chat explanation
to non-professional chess players what
makes that 7-piece table base so useful
so basically for those of you who don't
know Leach has announced that they they
have a seven piece table base
implemented and it's useful because any
position with seven or less pieces and
is now solved which opens up a lot of
interesting opportunities to analyze
even like very high level games where
seven piece positions were reached and
basically with any position seven pieces
or less you can see okay how many moves
will it take to mate the opponent and
also whether or not it's a draw with
perfect play so it's it took like an
insane amount of computing power because
if you think about all the possible
legal positions with seven pieces it's
well over trillions and trillions and
trillions I can take this I believe
and also I think they they discovered
like the longest forcemeat using the the
table base longest forests mates is like
over a thousand moves which is also
pretty crazy from a some very strange
position there is a blog article on me
chess which has a lot more information
though okay so he's not taking this pawn
I'm not sure whether I need to defend it
I think I can just play rock a3 if you
take Sun b7 I take on a3 your could be 2
mm maybe I should defend it yeah let's
play b5 I'm in no rush
I'm not Russian actually I'm half
Russian but a different kind of Russian
I guess Russian and rushing anyway I'm
not scared of this unless use Fischer
but then I would just trap him okay I've
really fallen behind the chat also no
hablo espanol lo siento pero no hablo
mucho soy de America
soy de murica okay uh
efore so he wants to open some file or
he wants to play e5 thinking about just
capturing and then play Knight b6 and
going for one of these uh one of these
squares to target c3 it should be good
enough
once I started attacking the paga it's
not that easy for him to defend Bishop
c6 is a good move which I kind of
realized he could play at right after I
played Knight b6 though it shouldn't be
to harmful I can play 95 here 95 should
be good enough
he can't take with rook actually he
can't yeah he can't take this pawn with
either piece if he takes with rook
there's back ring mates takes with
Bishop I had for him if he takes on d5
then I'll have the the Queen side
majority uh uh yeah okay so someone's
sharing the number of positions thanks
for that hello to me flying toasters I
don't think Lee chest yeah Lee chest
doesn't give the the then Nate it gives
like the DT Z which is slightly
different how can you get a game
unfortunately we don't have Nathan here
to answer everyone's questions but if
you want to challenge me you can use the
challenge command accept the challenge
command is wrong because you can
challenge me two games over five minutes
let me see if I can change that also can
I just take on c3 looks appealing
he can't take because of tactics she
because of mate
yeah I'll accept challenges I will also
accept challenges involving the way I
have to win a game my opponent says
whoops okay good game
Mac or Windows I have both Mac and
Windows I'm using a Mac right now I
prefer it for most things let me see if
I can change this moobot command which
will give people time to challenge me
moobot commands command list challenge
I don't know how to save it Oh safe okay
now it should be better let me see
challenge yes okay beautiful okay let's
pick another random number 18 give me a
random number between 1 and 18 okay so I
have to count backwards so 18 17 16 15
sorry Krishna no sigh Krishna okay sigh
Krishna good luck have fun challenge
play horde mode challenge can't use a
small piece to find a small piece you
have to go from minus 5 to +5 before
winning I could do that this is casual I
could give Queen odds is my opponent
here he's here okay
challenge accepted so this is the first
challenge I've sealed from minus 5 to +5
according to stocked fish and win the
game
I think the easiest way to do that is
just sacking the Queen um if I take the
knight it should be minus 5 already
right it's like minus 6 okay I don't
know if my point will know what's coming
unless he's watching and he'll know it's
coming I'll take the knight on f3 okay
so now I'm it's like minus 6 for luck
and now I have to come back and win life
before the game he said thank you so
much for accepting he was looking for
perhaps a more serious game anyway this
will hopefully be a good demonstration
of how to fight back
with uh with having less material in
this case having a having the absence of
the Queen though I do have a queen for a
night I've played many games before
where I give Queen odds just trade up
Queen odds and I've realized like the
hippo structure is usually the the best
approach where I just want to keep the
position closed and I want to avoid
trades also hello - I'm singer hello -
shinobi
hello and ihab I'm not gonna combine
challenges someone saying I can't touch
my Knights I need my Knights to win this
game so the great thing about this
structure is that whenever he pawn
breaks in the center I'll just close the
position so if he plays this I play this
if he plays this ok I win his queen so
the center will not open up
and in the meantime I just want the
complete development start with a nice
and I'll probably fee and keto and
castle and I'll just pretend that I
still have my queen I'll pretend I still
have a queen on d8 it's not going to
move and I'm just up at night I always
have to look on the bright side even if
it's a slightly delusional viewpoints so
I play a h6 here to prevent Bishop g5 I
played g6 Bishop g5 could have been
annoying
okay now b4 is kind of a standard move
by the way and then okay he might bring
the knight to the Kings side but at
least I'm being restrictive I have a
pair of Knights
thanks for pointing that out and I'm not
sure if I'm going to castle at any
points also this is a good move because
I don't want the position to open I
don't want to lose a pawn I probably
have to capture I could play a five
could play b3
mmm yeah good move I'll capture
you love the new microphone Thanks it's
not a new microphone it's just a mic
that I borrowed but I hope the quality
of the sound is decent when I get back
home in a couple of weeks
I'll have another new microphone but I'm
gonna I'm gonna be ordering one of these
which I should get in like by next month
okay
let's just continue developing
sound is good in Australia I think
Bishop c6 is kind of necessary a my
opponents playing solidly so far but I'm
just I'm just trying to hold my own
develops have some time advantage Queen
g3 good move
and sometimes the key to these
physicians is just doing nothing and
then letting the opponent's
self-destruct this case it might be more
difficult but I mean let's do nothing
nothing move I slightly reinforce the h6
pawn
there is no increment so the goal is to
essentially just get him a long time
have a long game we have a game lasting
over 50 moves he's guaranteed to be in
some time some time trouble at some
point any big tournaments next year in
st. Louis every every few months there's
a big tournament in st. Louis I'll
probably be back sometime next year he
wants to play h5 good move I could play
h5 myself I was Bishop g5
now I'll just play King h8 changing my
mind I don't want my King to be on the
same diagonal as this Bishop I'm
planning to respond to this with this I
need to get to +5 oh so I can't flag him
I actually have to be aggressive I
forgot about that part of the challenge
wealthy flags and okay that's gonna be
difficult but I'll try
I have to start by being somewhat
aggressive or maybe the goal is to get
them in time trouble then he'll start
plundering it's another option
I do have a pair of nights interesting
move think I should take Oh taking don't
want to open the position too much
okay I'll move back looks like a really
passive move but just trying not to get
mated sometimes you have to not lose
before you can win such wisdom +5 or
exactly +5 exactly +5 no it's when they
say +5 I assume it's +5 or battery
so the good thing is my bishops now open
I know how this is gonna be possible I
would love to get a rook to an open G
file someday okay we'll take
the queenside is kind of opening up
things are still kind of controlled
maybe he's considering sacrificing on G
692 unexpected it's a bit passive I
guess he wants to attack the pawn
so let's defend I'm still playing
defensive chess what is this I'm going
to make frames now with that phrase and
put them all over my office oh and you
can have like a nice picture of like a
mountaintop or like some nature and put
it in like big bold words that'll be
nice motivational posters so he's just
targeting g6 strong play I don't want to
play Knight c8 but I might have to maybe
I could play e5 probably doesn't work I
don't want to play d5 it's a blocks of
Bishop so 9 c8 sad move but I'm keeping
things defended kind of attacking more
things
okay
yeah it's kind of an annoying position
because I can't really be aggressive I
just have to wait for him to to do
something I just saw my opponents
comment he says he's nervous which is a
good thing not that great at keeping a
poker face usually online it's so easy
to keep a poker face but if you if you
tell me your emotions makes it easier
for me to to sense fear go play rook
here it's a solid move I wanted to do
this but this could happen so I'm gonna
plan to do this and then this and again
with these pawns he doesn't have a
breakthrough he does this I do this if
he does suicide you this
okay now it's time to do this I don't
know though
now there's many options I'm going to do
this first
why'd you ask me does not have the
patience to play this it takes a lot of
patience use positions as long as it's
just about outlasting the opponent so
I'm attacking the pawn I actually have a
lot of different there's so many
different things I can target in his
position with my Knights I forgot about
that move I figure out he could take
with Czech but it's not the end of the
world as long as I'm keeping my Knights
but that was uh yeah that was probably
the first like obvious mistake that I
made because I'm allowing some trade but
I won the Jeep on some attack kind of
bishop in my nights he's trying to
attack to his powerful Queen
a few things to consider here I think
I'll just move back
the goal is to do this and someday this
somehow made him the easiest task
this is not easy let's do this
it's really not easy but we're both
approaching time trouble probably a good
thing as long as I don't blunder and he
blunders and it'll be a good thing
I left upon undefended you could take
the pawn if you'd like that was
unexpected I don't think that's a good
move though because I can just take the
pawn
now I'll have some attack like my my my
pieces are all having some potential
miss diagonals really nice for me still
maybe I'll play a 5 at some points maybe
I'll go for this
so he attacks the bishop
okay its retreats actually this pawn is
hanging
that's okay go in the corner okay now he
just walked on the same diagonal as my
Bishop f5 makes a lot of sense but I'm
gonna start with this move because I
think it just it applies so much
pressure now I have so many threats
there's so many different targets in the
position I'm still down a queen for a
night and a pawn but my night is about
to be very powerful but what night do I
want to put an F for probably the H
Knights conflicted but yeah just about
controlling more center
hey it's something I don't know what
that sound was
and II have with twitch Brian thanks
Andy
my opponents gonna flag and now I can
win the Queen back let's win the Queen
tempted to just take the bishop but it's
I don't think it's gonna be +5 it's
gonna be like +3 by the end of this game
or minus 3 she doesn't have time to take
this because this is attacked now my
next several moves are actually really
important because I have to build up a
winning enough advantage this is a good
move to start with just attacking this
in this Oh
that was a really good move by him keep
the rooks on the board okay now it's
plus 5 or minus 5 okay right analysis
board yes minus 8 and going back the
Queen sack was definitely what is it
after Queen take f3 is a minus 6 it
should be minus 6 just based on point
value or I keep getting minus and plus
confused so it's plus 7 point 7 okay
well that was fun a very big sway in
evaluation we can actually see the be
interesting to see the computer chart
and just see the the chart should go up
and then go down I'll be a nice parabola
of some sorts or just a semicircle
uh I don't know if I address anyone but
does anyone have any questions
people were just asking was there a
queen sac yes I intentionally sacked my
queen uh to recap anyone who just joined
I was challenged to play a game where I
I go from minus 5 to +5 or in this case
plus 5 to minus 5 somehow I managed
Kiyomi
Kiyomi is back she owe me it's been like
six months good to see you back yeah I
usually haven't been streaming at this
time more of my streams have been in the
morning
also thanks PI standards for for subbing
new challenge sac both nights sac both
nights our plunder both nights wait okay
so now people are giving more challenges
let me see something that I can do give
checkmate using only nights no other
pieces can be involved okay that should
be doable let's do that only nights
which might mean I have to promote
tonight's or something give me a random
number between 1 and 26 I have to count
I can count in Spanish uno dos tres
cuatro Cinco seis siete Ocho Nueve Diez
on Sado say ok I'm playing I'm playing
Hanoi ok Hanoi is a loyal viewer to the
chat or to the stream I should say boys
should be in the chat - good luck kadoya
so only knights
this place um okay this is casual that's
good let's play some crazy opening hadou
equals horrible is that Japanese I'll
trust Kiyomi with that but last time I
had ou beat me right yeah I remember
that game so I need to revenge on Hanoi
I'm playing okay it's good he's sinking
here I'm playing an opening which is
dubious but it's something I've been
very intrigued by recently lose a game
while listening to music I don't think
so and shower like the rain thanks for
subbing let's play Bishop c5 wait
there's a problem with this there's a
big problem with this okay we'll see
what he does Japanese tutor in the
chests hello Japanese tutor so there's a
couple Japanese speakers in the chat I'm
playing I wonder if his Japanese f3 what
is this this guy clearly does not listen
to Ben Feingold he is really interesting
though it's a pawn triangle I don't see
any immediate Attucks also I gave away
one night already which is maybe a bit
unfortunate let's play Knight h5
so I'm gonna have to promote like at
some points g3 good move
maybe f5 I just want to break open the
center this is I'm more developed than
than him let's Castle there's some nice
tension so whenever I want I can open
the the file
let's play b5 just pushing it's such a
weird position I just want to play b4
kick away the night east away from the
center like white side up looks solid
but trying to crack it to trade or not
to trade ok let's go for this by the way
if I fail this challenge of delivering
mate with only Knights then I have that
it has to keep going until the next game
so we'll see how this goes and yeah
there is a very well-known type of
checkmate that I'm going for that Kiyomi
has has mentioned not sure if it's gonna
be possible but will be worth a try I
like Bishop g4 keep the tension I just
want to play b4
9:8 for defending be too
got four looks attractive here let's
play off for trying to justify my night
being on each five and if he trades I'm
happy to take with Queen Bishop f2 he's
being very solid maybe Queen Queen f6
targeting b2
things could actually get really weird
from this position his remove here he
can play she makes things very spicy
he's not playing it I was scared of G
for trapping the Knights G for here mind
I can come back to f6 now as Bishop is
just depressed on G 2 this is reminding
me of checkers or drafts which I've been
playing a lot lately actually lead
Roth's org chess trainee just trainee
this is not your first time catching a
stream though right
cuz I've definitely seen you before okay
let's retreat the Queen the goal is to
trap his Knights which might be hard to
do because he's gonna play b3 but or
he's gonna play Knight c5 ok let's first
start with this so if he plays my c5 ib3
check and then the goal is to play wait
he's allowing b3 s b3 c3 well let's go
for it and then I said I was gonna say
the goal is good me to play Bishop a6 to
prevent him from castling but now and I
take B 3 is a threat guess I could take
on a 2 with the pawn I could take on g4
with the bishop looks fun to play rook
b8
not entirely sure what to do here I
really want to take on g4 and just suck
but it's probably not a good move
if I take on a to doesn't lead to the
greatest things ever okay let's play
rook b8 keep the tension just want to
see what he does I am down upon right I
have not won a single pawn that would be
an interesting challenge to win the game
without taking any pawns that would be
difficult
to win the game without losing upon
probably even more difficult anyway it's
all about meeting with the Knights
Queen d2 slightly unexpected unlimited
rice pudding thanks for the sub go go
for a bishop a6
unless I can sack on g4 also Queen JK 2
is at least a move to consider doesn't
work but it's interesting yeah let's
play Bishop basics
okay
well now he's he's connected the rook so
should probably do something about my
queen or about my pawn on b3 I take that
runs into trouble
like I have to take go go ahead and take
and play Queen b6 assuming he plays well
I'm expecting him to play this is not
going well can be very hard to meet with
the knight
as position so solid like this whole
formation central formation the only way
I can imagine winning this game and
succeeding the challenge is that if he
gets low on time starts playing quickly
blunders allows me to promote to
multiple nights doesn't resign and
doesn't flag that's a lot to ask for
like like even if I got a winning
position and I start managing to promote
feel like he was going to resign our
flag but we'll see
taking his time yeah before was expected
fortunately my queen Oh Queen a cheese
check I forgot that's check that's not
good well now I'm I just have to go into
survival mode like the previous game
this is really bad
he wins that he's forcing a Queen trade
let's do this I'll take with a pawn yeah
I'm not gonna succeed the challenge I
don't know if I'll succeed in and not
losing this game yeah for people who
have just joined might be confused about
what's going on maybe people in the chat
can explain every game or every few
games I'm attempting some
viewer-requested challenges I'm okay I'm
happy to keep Queens on the board have
to reposition my Queen to a happier
place
except this is not a happy position what
to do maybe this move breaks some file
and the goal is to put him in time
trouble
I can play Queen d7 it doesn't really
help much
what to do
very calm and controlled player
okay good thing is as bishop is just not
doing anything so essentially I'm I am
down a piece but he's down a bishop he's
that's my arguments let's play rook d6
they can think if you take side kick is
neither way in this case I'll have some
check
start with us expecting Bishop f1
because he's following the rules has
been Feingold kind of now my night wants
to come here it's a scary move
I'm gonna start the manoeuvre
it's also a scary move attacking so many
things
I'm setting up multiple traps here
multiple traps
what are the chances you get to play
against me one in 24 yeah this is really
bad I'm still surviving kind of I'm no
longer focused at all
a Czech meeting with with the Knights
especially after this move wow what a
move
this is not good I have no counterplay
oh did you I see one potential trick in
the position it's not even like a trick
though
might as well go for it
it's all about counter play my counter
play kind of kind of making him think
I wrote 88 unfortunate
well done enjoy not so Hanoi his
Japanese and Japanese meaning of his
name does not represent his play
maybe represents my play that was tough
I thought I was getting some chances but
yeah round here I forgot Queen take a 2
which was Czech so b4 is just crushing
so I had to be a bit more careful but
already in position is just really bad
well yeah I'll have to blame levy for
that one it's such a good coach I'll
love use faults okay uh why did Brooke
take night not work Brooke take night oh
yeah I mean at this point it's hopeless
if stockfish making me feel bad if I
take the Knights d6 is just like it's so
easy for white to play I was looking for
a counter play but just didn't see
anything
I had another trick I was thinking about
playing rookie 5 here which may be a
better practical try given that if take
here
it's hoping for something like this then
you're okay one should be good enough
anyway
oh good game yeah if you want to
challenge me feel free to challenge me
uh let's play okay so the challenge is
still active I have to checkmate only
using a night or multiple nights give me
a random number between one and twenty
five
okay well count backwards so that is now
that is 26 so 26 25 24 23 22 21 20 okay
okay this should be doable now let's
play d4 probably want to use some kind
of London start with the London develop
the bishops first and hopefully he
doesn't resign too quickly
Bishop f5 let's play Bishop e5 I just
want to take on c6 and then get the
Knight to e5 are you trying to imagine
some potential meet in Knight to e5
Knight to c7 win his queen somehow oh I
did allow him to take a night there but
I always have to keep in mind I can
always promote later so I think I just
want to win material and hopefully he
doesn't resign let's play this so I'm
keeping my Knights maybe the goal is to
trap his Bishop but maybe I shouldn't be
too extravagant g4 let's play g4
okay we have to train once I feel like
the challenge should not be too
difficult if I just get a winning end
game where I can just start promoting
tonight's this is a rated game too so I
have to watch out for rating what to do
maybe Queen g2 let's develop tonight
first I want to play up three I wanna
kick away the night somehow break
through and start winning material I'll
start with f3
and now okay keep kicking the Knights
yeah that was only move and now I'll
play this now the problem with this
position I have some like checkmating
attack but I can't end it in meat I just
have to end it by winning material h5 is
a good move
maybe I have to ok let's play g6 open
the G file probably put a rock on g1
neither when the h5 on or the e6 pawn
just put the rook on do you on
because I have to clarify what was a
challenge like if I have a piece
controlling a square that the king can
escape to and the knight is delivering
the meats that I'm not officially doing
the challenge because no other pieces
can be involved whether the ponent has a
piece taking way of square from the king
would that count because that would just
be a smothered meats are we ready
forgetting like who gave the challenge
he's not a bad player I think he's
provisional rated so he could have just
had bad luck his first game
okay so 1600 classical not bad Castle
queenside
so smother and make counts interesting
so as master Makara
but what about this mother inmate where
I'm like painting the pond and the pond
can't take the night's would that count
I probably wouldn't counts
okay let's save my Knights
I love this night it's so useful so many
different scenarios let's play this
I just want to triple up and the goal is
to win material and somehow promote so I
have 28 pending challenges you know the
whole names seems like a lot of new
names which is good to see c5 aggressive
but I can just take a free pond
I'm daydreaming about like taking the
night playing pawn g7 getting a knight
to f6 but that would be mate that's not
the man I want
but somehow like in some cases promoting
the jeep on to a Knights I'm getting
probably not possible so now the plan is
to double up I actually see a cool
threat from this position it probably
doesn't work I was thinking rook g1 and
then I can take on f6 and take here and
then play rook g7 and just win material
but he has King h8 okay now it's just
changing so I'll take on g7 now I can't
promote to a knight with a Jeep on one
of my pawns will eventually promote and
that's the goal
hmm just wants to trade well let's build
up pressure first I really don't mind
going into an end game as long as he
doesn't resign 9595 looks good
provoking the Queen trade I have a nice
outpost
nc6 could come in strong pod and it's
hard for black to remove the night keeps
Queens on the board
let's see six rooks g7 will be played
I'm thinking about 97 it looks wrong but
let's play it because it trades off the
night but I just want to promote a pawn
hey it's a sub I don't know what that
was it was a sound of some sorts but I
can't really see it I'll give a shout
out soon enough
yeah rook f7 is solid wait a minute
there could be a really cool tactic here
no maybe not no maybe wait okay so Queen
take Queen
take rook take g7 Queen take g7 and then
they take f6 King somewhere take take in
the 9 th the promise he has rook taken
and
I mean you have 98
looks crazy so can we take up seven
Queens egg f7 rotate g7 Queen take g7 I
take f6 there's King f8 yeah that
doesn't work at all what would have been
really cool if it works though so I'll
just go back and then I'll probably play
I'll probably play some different plan
like Queen d3 and then try to maybe I'll
just try and win the eight pond and then
pawn storm on the Queen side and I'm
threatening some fork possibilities
a queen itch queen age six I don't think
did anything maybe it did unleashes a
rook actually maybe it was a good move
but I have other ambitions my yeah my
count is not set to auto promote
Queen g6 not easy I could take on g7 go
for Queen g6
I mean I know seven in the end just
doesn't work so let's play this just
have to be patient sometimes and
patience is key
I need seven looks very suspicious don't
know if I can punish it just looks wrong
though you know I could win the H five
fun you could take on g7 Queen g6 no
smothered mate there unfortunately let's
just take on each five win upon row got
five eye cream with another pond
now I'm sensing some smaller mate
possibilities just need the King to come
here rook to come here and then the
right to come here oh this is so close
to working I don't want to make him
resign though don't resign
because in order tonight mate I really
want to keep the rook on the board I'm
not seeing the smothered mate like Queen
ch-check raka fades
okay so here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna win the Queen
while keeping my nights
I took too many of his pieces for her
smothered mate to happen though actually
wait maybe I can hope for keep it on the
board for just another move now I'm
threatening the night fork so I'm hoping
he plays Queenie g8 here I'd be the the
biggest hope
just trade Queens I'm threatening in the
fork Queen gee that's out of the fork
but he's thinking that's a very complex
position many other suggestions in the
chat
so I am threatening Maidan 1 but it
doesn't fulfill the challenge I wonder
if he's watching I wonder if he like
knows what's going on
let me play this
9fa it's okay go for the promotion I'm
hoping it won't require more than two
nights but it might require more than
two nights yeah I'm gonna gonna trade
Queens promote to a nights so where's a
mate
maybe it's just easier if I promote you
and other nights
I feel like been Feingold right now I
feel so dirty so wrong but I guess it's
fun I can promote to a lot more nights
it's when the pond first
trying to like imagine the mate with
upon g7 and the Knights kind of looming
around but it's not I don't think it's
possible so I'm gonna have to get rid of
my rook somehow please just take it
doesn't want to take my rook I can still
take it okay oh I got forked wait no I'm
losing up future Knights that was a
tragic mistake
well now I'll chop the night so now
there's gonna be no more Forks and I'm
gonna forcibly sack the rook and then
that night could have grown up to do so
many great things King b3 is coming
Capri move this even
oh my king can't play a role so I might
be tricky
this stalemate that's tell me it's okay
I can't stalemate the king
it's so weird stalemate let's play this
hello Esther Chen you've joined at a
time I feel very bad for my opponent and
for the people who are watching probably
waiting to play me just waiting for this
game to end
okay let's start pre moving
this is part of a challenge so like I
was I was challenged to do this I'm
about to succeed I hope as long as I
don't mess up terribly
that's not stalemate but I want to play
there play here first really have to be
careful about stalemates it's a scary
thing
don't want to hang anything this is
checkmate but my king would play a role
in the mates that's really annoying so
let's move here and let's bring my king
to somewhere also I have to avoid 50
move rule - when did I promote on move
ok move 84 so I have until move 134
here we go
this was pretty brutal
this was really brutal
that's nice it's a classic night Nate
six nights very aesthetic okay talk to
games
looks like horde but with nights nice uh
thanks to the one subscriber whose name
I didn't mention I'm the singer with the
sub thanks I'm singer beats me and then
subs to me nice combo
can I move the same piece twice in a row
I don't think so that's just that's
absurd
I will take all their challenges though
if anyone wants to throw a challenge
scroll up here oh I could tweet this I
could tweet it like and always does and
then post it on social media let's get
rid of the highlights nice okay that'll
be my tweets get nine Queens without
checkmating no mates by moving my king
okay me by moving my king let's see okay
I've dirty one pending challenges give
me a random number between 1 and 31 the
answer is 5 1 2 3 4
Thaddius I think I played before
good luck Thaddeus I have to meet by
moving my king
I already have an idea of what opening
I'm going for let's start with like I'm
moving for a four nights mmm that's
annoying
leh Bishop c5 how long have I been
streaming for there's a command for that
it's called uptime okay so we have some
kind of quiet Italian game the mate I'm
already visualizing is when the G file
opens when he takes on on f6 and then
I'll play something like King g7 rook h8
and then tried to play some eventual
King h8 with mates all along an open G
file
it's very far-fetched but we'll see if
if it comes to reality wonder if he's
watching now he knows my my top secret
plan
okay step one completed is to open the G
file
step two is gonna be hard because some
somehow I have to get rid of this Jeep
on probably requires sacrificing might
require some slower play to
yeah I could move I'll take and play
nine at four it's all about creating
some attack like I just want to open the
Kings side open the G file and then I'll
try and create the meet
so my next move is probably like King h8
rope g8 and so I like my night I like my
bishop have to improve the major pieces
Bishop h3 till I have Bishop h3 maybe
Bishop page 3 could have been some idea
g3 thinking about sacking the Knights
it's difficult though
let's play c6 just want to see what he
plays
I would be happy to trade the night for
the bishop also thanks for the raid MC
jgp I don't think that's Eric Hanson
even though he has a picture of Eric
Hanson I appreciate it though also I
have no idea why there's no like alert
notifications because they're supposed
to be but also I'm the singer donating
twenty dollars and there is no
notification Wow thanks I'm singer I
didn't even like realize that that
happens
I appreciate the generosity being me and
then donating to me so I guess that
wasn't a son donation
okay queen g4 makes me happy cuz rook G
it will come with tempo King eh it was
him if I wanted to play anyway and my
prediction for the maid is is King H a
checkmate
within the next 20 moves it's still
gonna be hard to pull off we'll see what
happens
Esther Chen recent I have no idea what's
going on have to check my notification
thing could just be a stream Labs issue
oh let's play d5 because why not a
strong center
I learned the center from M singer So
Solid pawns of the center pawns to
reinforce its
rook g8 is on the horizon and then
probably some idea of tripling up on the
G file so G 3 could be a potential
sacking square let's do this
yeah create the Alekhine's gun I'd be
nice
g4 was g4 let's play this
okay files are opening it still kind of
required putting my king on one of these
squares in putting a major piece behind
it also hoping that he doesn't resign
this is such a nice attack though please
don't resign okay this is falling
there's a pin here
I can't let him flag either it's a
problem in these situations they started
taking a lot of time and then they're in
a situation later where they might flag
ok free queen but you I want to take the
Queen she considering not capturing the
Queen yeah I think I'll play Rock g8
forest most people most normal people
would capture the Queen but oh that the
queen is still gonna be lost and more
more concerned about just optimizing
everything
probably take the Queen next move if he
leaves it hanging
doesn't leave it hanging so how am I
gonna do this with King h8 rook g3 could
lead to an immediate mates
hmm this is not easy okay I'm gonna go
for Roachy - like it's so dominant but
it's tricky at the same time
now I probably just want to win the
Queen I take H three Queens edge free I
can't take the Queen without meeting him
let's just play Queen h4
probably going to win the f2 pawn
I like all my pieces attacking
has to be good
problem is in order to play King h8
mates he can't block and he like anyway
on the G file so I essentially have to
win his Queen and his Bishop okay well
now I can play this such a fun position
okay so he takes that's a good sign good
start
let's take here
oh no oh okay I guess that's fine it
just makes it more difficult for me okay
he could have taken the bishop would
have made things a lot more difficult
still very tricky though this bishop is
solid let's get rid of it
okay making progress Bishop has nowhere
to hide unless it goes here but this is
good progress and now here's a plan
that's gonna be King g8 mates oh I
forgot about that should still be okay
though okay let's fork don't resign
okay challenge succeeded King g8 mates
that was nice what a game time for a
night game I think that was a good
opening choice is like these 45 openings
where black gets double pawns
you have to imagine these files opening
up at some point rail bird no I can't
stock fish I think would be too good in
defending Nets and I honestly haven't
studied that in game in Queen Queen
versus rook I think is slightly too
challenging anyway I do like studying
openings to leo fonseca move all my
pawns before i move a piece okay let's
do that give me a random number between
1 and 25 I have to count 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 so great games is number 10 11 and
12 13 14 15 16 17
okay good luck
this is gonna get ugly uh this is gonna
get really ugly
I like this challenge though because I
could succeed it like the first first
aid moves and then and then just have a
game I don't have to stress out about
exceeding the challenge okay this guy's
probably thinking I'm crazy where he's
thinking about how he can make me
knowing that I have to move pawns oh
yeah this is Siri I just have an iPhone
so makes life easy let's play h3 halfway
there just have four more pawns to move
and he's just trying to play Sala P
which is great for me because I just
want to I just want to move pawns g3 he
prevented g4 but he didn't prevent g3
cake rats
thanks for watching mmm let's play f3
preventing any bishop efore her the vid
i bade f4 and he played Bishop efore I
would have been in big trouble
also if he captured on c2 I would have
failed the challenge because I wouldn't
haven't had a chance to move the C pawn
also that's kind of scary let's play
this still still moving my pawns and now
I have officially moved all the pawns
before moving any pieces I'll top it off
by playing h4 and now I have the classic
checkers formation this is great timing
because now I can move my queen I'll
have to find some way to break through
should be possible oh man my phone is at
1% probably find a charger somewhere
where I don't see it okay so the goal in
this position is to simply attack on
that Queen side like probably going for
some I'm just some attack the pieces
maybe I'll play queen bee three and a
four
be right back
okay I got my charger not easy to break
through but it's not easy for a black to
do anything I'm just gonna complete
development my light squares are it's
sort of a nightmare but it's okay I'll
play around them if only half the board
which are light squares also kiyomi
these are not Windows I can prove it
it's just a cabinet but it has it has
drapes for some reason it's old-school I
did not design this house phone is not
gonna die Bishop f5 is a good move I
don't want to open up the position too
much
yeah they look like Windows you really
look like Windows
so let's improve I know okay we can
trade now Queen b3 a simple plan a 4 B 5
yeah the windows are on the other walls
in front of me and to the side of me I
could prove it
people want to see the window there's a
window I'm no longer sitting like in
front of the window with the window in
the background because people were
messing with me the other day and it was
slightly annoying anyway its king/queen
verse king rook winning or Jon it's
winning unless there is a special case
where black is like forcing stalemate b5
so he's doing the same kind of Sakura
structure also I have a match coming up
I don't think I have announced this I
guess I can go ahead and announce it on
Wednesday wait no not on Wednesday on
Thursday I'm playing penguin GM in a two
two and a half hour deathmatch and drops
it will be played on lead Roth's orange
but it will be promoted on HS org and I
think we'll both be streaming and it'll
be exciting
anyway let's Viking f2 maybe rook to you
one ninety two
and figure something out King g7
okay let's put the rook here I don't
know why I just didn't castle I could
have castled I would have made life so
much easier like King g1 yeah apparently
Andrew has a like the top ultra bullet
rating on the sights so he's fast but
I've been studying I've been doing
tactics trainer been looking up opening
videos tactics it's on Thursday at noon
Central Time oh this is kind of attacked
okay I feel good about this position
there's lots of lots of progress to be
made my g5 could be coming if you takes
on a4 I'm sacking no doubt
I'll just play this this is difficult to
actually break through
I guess I'm happy to take the night or
maybe I can play let's take the night
first and take the night and then play
Queen d1 it's such a close position just
play this
what is rook h8
what is he trying to accomplish a
battery on the a file
it's my bishop is just as sad as his
rooks but not okay now this rook is
happy that's a free pawn he was trying
to exploit this diagonal but doesn't
quite work
now it's just a matter bring my other
rook into the game you're supposed to
put your rooks on open files and not
close violence
I'm not pretty moving work f2 because he
could play some move like Bishop f3 but
okay rook F to the plan I actually have
a threat here thingy for and then if he
takes my check and I'll win his queen
life is good my bishop will come alive
his Queen will be lost at some points
who will be the next victim
time situation is good okay let's take
the bishop now my bishop is so happy I
could have taken on c6
I'll come very soon
probably my longest dream you have
school tomorrow
and you're probably in the u.s. that's
rough
yeah if you have school tomorrow and you
have to wake up at like 7:00 a.m. or 6
a.m. go to sleep there's no need to
watch this ridiculousness
there'd be a funny case if like he had a
couple more pawns and we traded Queens
there's some cases where it could be a
draw because the rook can't penetrate
but okay this is easy win de Yan Eve is
late for work I'm so sorry you can just
blame me for all your problems let's do
this
yeah so a position like this okay now
it's just easy win good game
your shod 2088 school starts early yeah
I think I'm gonna end it here that was
fun
accepted was it three challenges playing
a king mate doing the knight mates
pushing all pawns he goes just three I'm
not gonna play drafts but I am going to
raid another streamer who's even more
popular than me I have to find him
better still be streaming his name is
John
she's streaming yes he's streaming okay
we're rating John Bartholomew
so fuel free to join the raid on the
count of three one two